at the age of 10 10 years old
you accidentally hit a girl with a bat
how did that happen we're playing a game
called hit the bat
right where you hit the ball and you
catch it
and then you roll it towards the bat and
you hit the bat and it bounces up
and you have to catch it right or it's
your turn up you know and
and i used to throw the ball at the bat
so anyway
the bat hitter right so because you were
the quote-unquote bag kid
they accused you of hitting her with a
bat on purpose yeah oh i hit her with a
bat
and it's like do you start to think even
at 10 years old
everything in my life always goes bad
and it had an accident things are
stacked against you yeah like this
ran i just ran the police were coming so
i just ran and then so when you
accidentally hit her the police took you
and at 10 years old you went into what
juvie
yeah but just for like you know they
take you to scare you and
the biggest problem with trying to scare
a kid is that if you don't scare him
then he's no longer scared scared of
that punishment right
so basically i just you know i just
started going to juvenile home
when you went to juvenile hall you
describe it as one of the scariest
places you've ever been when you first
walk in absolutely
and that's when you realized hey if i'm
not the strongest guy
out there if i don't toughen up i am
going to get my ass kicked in life
well it's it's kind of like uh
being on a you know like a pile of [ __ ]
you don't want to be on the bottom
right and if you're going to grow up in
that jungle you've
got to you've got to be on top so how do
you prepare yourself mentally is that
when your uncle took
that's when my uncle that was this phone
call
you know if you get in a fight and you
try to bite somebody in the neck people
tend to leave you alone right you've
even said you don't have to be the best
fighter in the world you got a crazy
fight
you got to fight like a wild man well
you know it's it's amazing
it's amazing how howard the the further
up the ladder you go
in prison the less you fight because it
is actually
easier in prison to get away with
stabbing somebody
right than it is a fight it's
unbelievable how tough you are i mean
i heard this great story about you
you've got this uh great uh
ted you've got a lot of tats uh the one
on your chest yeah covers your whole
church what is that of the one
it's a mexican lady it's a mexican lady
wow with a
with a sombrero who is that harry super
jew ross did that
i got to say that but tell the story
this was one of his first tattoos
right and i was doing forever so harry
says let me do this tattoo danny
so we did the outline you trust him to
do it because he had never done one
before
so he does the outline right and then
when he does outline i get
caught up in some [ __ ] in prison and
squinting and they send me to folsom
and harry had just done this huge
outline
so he says don't let anybody touch it
i'll be in full so i'll be involved in
once okay so
so i got the folsom i was there and then
about six months later he showed up
how did he get into folsom he just yeah
how do you get kicked out of san quentin
it's funny when he got the votes hey
it's jail here
so so he did the rest of it some of it
in in
folsom and then the there's a big riot
in
in a race right in folsom and they sent
me to soledad
and he said danny please man this is my
first tattoo let me finish it let me
okay so i waited for him to solid that
he finished it so you went to three
prisons to get that tattoo and
it was howard he hated this tattoo it
was his first tattoo
so you know as a tattoo you get better
and better
well this guy became a a real well-known
tattoo artist in the biker world for
this beautiful work that he did
and he hated this one because it was his
first one and it made him famous
absolutely famous and and you got to be
careful when you get a
tattoo in prison right because some of
these guys don't have the cleanest
conditions
well yeah you don't worry about that
yeah you know what the hell it doesn't
look like you're going anywhere
that's like a bad haircut in prison so
what how does a guy
like me if i have to go to prison i'm
[ __ ] dead what do you do how do you
i mean you know do you i think anybody
that is going to make it
in prison however you're gonna make it
right all right if
if you're gonna be a a predator
then then you become somewhat of a
sociopath somewhat of an unfeeling
scrum they had you we got i remember i
remember
uh an incident when we were playing
dominoes right
it was we were playing diamonds before
the big game because a lot of money on
it
and i got a run of fives and anybody
that knows dominoes i got four
fives in my hand and i'm like look and
right here this guy
watched this guy that was watching had
snitched on something and
so boom boom boom boom boom they hit him
about six times
in the back with a knife bang bang bang
and he falls on the domino table
right and i got this run of five and i
remember going oh my god wait no wait
i'm trying to push this guy
so he was in the middle of getting
killed yeah and i'm going
no no when somebody gets stabbed
well it shouldn't upset you well you you
know you have to get away from there
because if you're near there you did it
right right do you understand so
i'm like no no wait wait i'm getting
everybody's come on we got away i got
back to myself
with this damn run of fives everybody
had thrown their dominoes away they last
i got into my cell i still got this damn
run of fives and i
was laying there myself and it hit me
what am i becoming you know what i mean
a guy just got
stabbed to death and you're sitting
there you were ready to sit there and
play diamonds right
and i just i never i've never forgotten
that i remember like
like keeping the dominoes and going back
out the yard after
all and i remember
showing one of my partners the dominoes
and they said
you're [ __ ] up yeah i mean you're a
scary guy
it's so it's so true because you know
when you think about it
you become so hard into things here's a
guy being stabbed to death right in
front of you and like you're just
worried about a domino game that's when
you know holy mackerel
i'm turning into something i don't even
recognize and so so
by the way and this guy was a snitch
that's why they gave him the [ __ ] yeah
you know he
who knows what he did you know he still
had them why did they have to kill this
why they have to kill this [ __ ] guy
right on top of a dominant yeah that's
it
come on you're like you're having the
greatest luck of your life and the worst
of your life all at the same time it's
just unbelievable
that was a good analogy